foreign
[Music]
you guys are in for such a treat tonight
um at film independent we've done live
reads for I don't know seven or eight
years I don't know if anyone here has
attended them but we took the the basic
idea is we take a classic screenplay
something that is a truly beloved and we
ask a current working director to come
in and reinterpret that with actors on
stage there is no rehearsal there's no
filming this is a one-time only you have
to be in the room to experience it and
tonight we are so honored to have Marvin
lemus the creator of hentify coming out
hentified amazing show second season
just dropped damn straight
[Applause]
um you know Marvin is telling the story
of Los Angeles in that show and we can't
think of a better director to take on um
Steve Martin's classic and beloved
script now celebrating its 30th
Anniversary but with that please join me
in a Rowdy welcome for filmmaker Marvin
lemus
thank you everybody I uh I'm so excited
to be here tonight to to do this and
direct this live read I brought together
an amazing amazing a bunch of friends
and a great cast for you tonight this
somebody backstage just told me that
this is the first time that they've had
an all-latinx cast
so we could just wow the cast that is
reading for you tonight the LA story
thank you so much they turn a corner
into a TV studio on the countdown three
two one he jumps in front of the TV
cameras to take his position in front of
a weather map okay here's the report
muggy followed by toggy Wiggy and Fergie
seriously though Tuesday 72 Wednesday 72
Thursday watch out 73
Friday 72 again Saturday is your mystery
day maybe rain maybe Sun Sunday watch
out 72 again surprise later in the lunch
Trudy introduces Sheila to Harris Sheila
has been taking a course in the art of
conversation
oh so you've been studying the art of
conversation
[Music]
break up with someone they
went much too young for them she's not
so young she'll be 27 in four years
having sex with my agent again I've told
you a thousand times she looks up
shocked how did you know
I was right
I was right I was making a bad joke my
eight flank
and this is how I find out you tell me
oh he's not
he's not happy about it either we just
decided that I should tell you oh my God
I thought he was only supposed to take
10 percent
[Laughter]
Sarah just got off a plane from London
he must be exhausted nothing some
sleeping a good fuck wouldn't kill him
I'm sorry I've been on a plane for 12
hours to next to an infant crying how
old ah mid to late 40s
[Music]
an earthquake everyone keeps talking as
if nothing is happening
you know what they say about La is not
the heat it's the pity
[Applause]
[Music]